conflict zone this week is an Amsterdam
general elections are a week away our
guest Hunton Brooker is chairman of the
dutch parliament defense committee his
government could be swept away by the
populism that has stunned the Western
world over the last year will the
Netherlands be next
[Music]
huntin burger welcome to conflict zone
let me quote a recent poll 61% of
respondents see Dutch politicians as
elitist and reliable and dishonest I
think this is a phenomenon that we see
throughout the Western world in many of
the Western democracies including France
or Great Britain or 61% wouldn't be the
result of a poll this is really
tremendous more than the half of your
population is yeah well we have so many
polls that go around
I mean I'm believe yes I'm not going to
diminish it this in any way I think
confidence and trust in modern-day
Western societies is really at a at a
very low point and we can also see why
because there is so many threats so many
external threats internal threats they
seem to collide people are worried that
they can still lead the comfortable
lives between to be worried and not to
trust any more government or even to say
that politicians are elitist I mean
these 61% are also referring to your
party to your Prime Minister to you
personally yeah well to me personally I
haven't I haven't seen that but if that
is the case then I would love to see
your to see your figures but I can
understand let me say this we have a
situation in Western democracy including
the Dutch democracy where compromise is
not being seen as an honorable thing
anymore
we have democracies that are fragmented
like the Dutch democracy currently in
Dutch parliament we see about 15 parties
so there is a tremendous amount of
voices let's talk honestly this is a
drama for democracy now this is a drama
for a party for a prime minister it is a
little bit too easy to say this is a
problem of the Western democracy this is
perhaps a problem of this country and of
the leadership of this country
I'm not trying to run away from this
statistic or your analysis I think it is
probably there is a lot that can be said
about that but you also need to
understand and see that for example the
turnout in our in our elections still
goes up until 80 percent now can the
American democracy can they still say
they have a turnout of 80 percent so
despite of the trust issues despite of
the confidence the lack of confidence
the deficit in confidence towards
politicians indeed including myself
there is still this tremendous energy
vibrant discussion that's a very good
point tremendous energy next week your
country goes to the polls and the
far-right leader get builders could win
the most votes again what is going on
here in this country he could this is
throughout a possibility and that's why
we are campaigning very hard as you have
probably noticed also against his
platform and his ideas if there are any
but it strikes me that you just quoted a
survey but you're not quoting the
surveys that are currently being done
about where he stands in the polls
because he's actually going down in the
polls and 1% more or less you are really
well next to the absentee but the case
is the case is that still get builders
has a very successful result and you
will have also successful result this
elections if you let me let me let me
tell you something
kid will this is running on
anti-immigrant anti Islamic platform
that we see in other countries as well
this is a popular sentiment that goes
very much to the heart of the anxieties
of many people and many of those people
that I meet on a day-to-day basis well
campaigning at this very moment they
feel that we haven't been listening to
them and I think to to large extent they
are right but here build us and this is
not very known or not very unnoticed has
lost the last four elections in a row
this is your prime minister mark
has promised not to join builders in a
coalition indeed should we believe him
absolutely he said so how can I believe
somebody if we're going back a few years
ago back in 2010 mark Mbutu only become
prime minister because he reached a deal
with vilnius if it happened once it
could happen again
no because the last time we reached the
deal with vilnius by the way there was a
deal where he was not inside of the
government and will this basically went
from zero percentage in the polls to 12
to 15 percent and you cannot rule out a
party has been growing absolutely i work
personally with these people so i and
you know what you know what is the
absolute perfect antidote to a populist
party
the antidote to pockets so why don't you
try it again this is the best medicine
it means that in 2017 you make it again
the best no in this case it won't happen
and i will tell you why it won't happen
this time because this time around he
has radicalized so much that his program
the platform he's running on you think
so he radically is this time ok then
let's go back to 2010 at that time he
said stop islam defend freedom it was
July 2010 and at that time you worked
with him so he was radicalized a few
years ago he's still radicalized so if
do I get you right that when a
politician in Western open democracy
says stop Islam that he should be ruled
out well let's just see what we did and
what he did he compromised and by doing
so he lost four elections in a row he
went out it became too hot in the
kitchen for him and he went on this you
were working with a man who said Islam
is a fascist religion and you still
worked with them at that time
I mean fascist religion well do you
believe he's well he wasn't in
government sir he was not in a movie
made him Jerry had the Prime Minister
without his help he was supporting you
in what he was a militia but without him
no Prime Minister so my question is
again seven years ago you had a
relationship with this guy why not this
year
who can trust you well if you let me
finish then I can turn I can tell you
why he radicalized I mean these were
slogans and we have a very large degree
of freedom in terms of our freedom of
speech so politicians can say a lot here
now in this time around in other
countries well but there are
consequences political consequence and
on this time around he runs on a
platform where he breaks basically in
one slide of paper which is his total
program he breaks three constitutional
rules freedom of religion freedom of
speech freedom of gathering I mean if
you want to abandon if you have won a
half Muslim people abandon their holy
book if you want them to not only not
pray anymore in their mosques but
actually close down the most I mean last
time around he didn't want to build X
almost now in last time around we're on
with mine cups it cannot get a more
primitive and racist argument and for
two years
you didn't care power was always more
importantly it was mine Kampf Quran no I
mean what you're doing now is you're
quoting solve his most extreme that's
the same thing his most extreme no
statements of today but this is just
interesting it's Italy nothing change is
the platform Michele that he's running
on which is entirely different he runs
on a platform when it closed down
mosques forbidding a holy book we have 1
million Muslim people in this country
most of them are law-abiding citizens
like all of us let's talk about mark
route
2017 now your Prime Minister is using
using Vilnius rhetoric on immigrants
urging all citizens to integrate he said
quote she said oh he said be normal or
be gun what means to be more normal
what is this normal actually he said the
opposite no he said it's a quote be
normal or be gone no in Dutch I mean
it's a little bit of a feeling that you
need to have for the language
he actually said yesterday it's not act
normal maybe this was a girl it was a
few days ago and the word was normal
what does it mean to be normal no live
up to the rules that is what it means in
dimitru is the Constitution sir basic
constitutional rights
nobody needs to behave ordinary this is
Amsterdam this is the one of them the
freest cities in the world you hardly
see any conformity
people around which we like we're
liberals okay thank you for the lesson
well thank you for the lesson really a
good one Ruta took out a full-page
advertisement in newspaper saying now
you will certainly give me again the
opportunity to learn some Dutch if you
reject our country I prefer you leave
this could be a quote for mr. builders
well it could be a quote of me or you if
you are a lover of liberal open
democracies I think we should stand for
the rules that keep our countries open
keep our countries free and keep trust
within society now let me explain to you
what it means because he said it both to
people who are new to a country and
maybe new to the rules that have been
emancipated in this country for the last
400 years but also the people that live
here have always lived here
25% voters for builders this is an
emancipated modern country well I think
you see you see you see nationalist
movements you see populist movements
right-wing even left-wing these days
around Europe in your country you know
that you want to speak about other
countries but are not complaining in
your own country so let me ask there are
too many Muslims in your country No do
you think that the security of the
Netherlands is at a risk because of
Muslims are living in your country I
think we have a security problem as soon
but this goes for everyone including of
course Muslim that would for example
advocate Sharia law
or a attitude that's right no don't try
again because I'm still finishing or an
attitude or a towards our Constitution
towards the open society that we cherish
so much
another topic in and the campaign is
that the far-right no longer once the
eurozone and to be a member of that they
are demanding a referendum on the
European currency do you do - no I don't
we are against referenda and we're very
much against me I'm vehemently against
an exit I mean you can see now what the
tremendous well detrimental you are so
can you explain me effect can you
explain me your Parliament has launched
an inquiry on the future of the Europe
this is unique France didn't do that
it's a review that even the Greece
didn't do that and it was with the
backing of your party I would say if one
cannot challenge what is in what we have
especially when it comes to Europe this
project that we if we want to survive if
we want the projects to survive he want
to survive within the project this whole
project has been about the euro problem
yes speaking I will get your mirror over
promise and under deliver even with the
euro with the euro we've made some grave
mistakes some grave mistakes for example
let in Greece be part of the euro you're
now sometimes serves a little it was a
mistake as a straightjacket I don't
agree was certainly a mistake I think
some other countries might also have
better joint later or not joint at all
will you prefer that Greece is leaving
the eurozone no I mean we've done our
utmost to prevent that from happening
because Greece leaving the eurozone
would have meant that the Euro would
have would have fallen and that would
have taken us all down our banks our
pensions our welfare etc you are
founding member of the European Union
Treaty of Rome signed nearly 60 years
ago had a Dutch senior signature net and
now 1/5 of Dutch voters support
far-right populist who wants to leave
the EU
the euro yes what has happened to the
Netherlands Islamophobia racism and more
than 20% 1/5 at 20% out themself as
racist
their vote to help villages well we have
to wait and see today we're one week
ahead of the general elections as I just
told you hit Willis now has lost for the
elections in a row he might do a very
good result next week he might also not
let's wait and see so the result we
can't wait and see is the situation with
turkey during the Dutch presidency of
the you last year your prime minister
was instrumental in implementing the
deal with turkey to stem the flow of
refugees into Europe deal around he
criticized by human rights groups whose
still supported I think it is one of the
perfect examples that we rarely see of
successful European foreign this is now
what we wanted is stem the flow of my of
refugees it has happened spectacularly
we have seen over the last month that
just one person drowning that one person
is still too much but we do not see the
gruesome theater that we saw one year
ago in January where 227 people this is
rad perspective no it was one
perspective but this is a very backward
the reason that's ok today go listy it's
an against egoistic point of view it's a
Unitarian respective or but but would
you accept that what less than if we
diminish the amount of people that are
drowning because there's anything that
change if you do not know the difference
between the route Turkey Greece and
Libya which is of course a new problem
and here 2/3 of the migrants that come
from Libya and there's many more when
the weather is getting better and here
we have the same problem now making a
deal with Libya is impossible case there
is no there is no but making a deal with
Turkey and Mister the president are the
one who is
No viewing Hauser welcome to the real
world and this is the real word
it is the real world we are surrounded
we Europeans are surrounded by some very
authoritarian awkward this countries
don't want to deal with them then you
don't do deals at all that means that
you're not dealing with the problems and
the prospects of Europe and you want to
have European foreign policy here you
have it that's very difficult you about
values hi this is all about value I just
gave you
ok so let's speak about NATO's a
molecular amount of people a less amount
of people getting drowned I think that's
a humanitarian less that should be come
let's talk about right let's talk about
NATO NATO members commit themselves I'm
quoting safeguard the freedom and
civilization of their people founded on
the principles of democracy individual
liberty and the rule of law do you
believe that your partner in this
organization is still representing and
fighting for these values yes or no the
deal we dealt with the criticism I just
gave you my prime minister actually
criticized out in the open no other pure
PM leader has so far followed so I give
me one in Europe and now on Turkish
membership on the unlight Oh have you do
you know have you any idea how many
conflicts turkey has on its external
borders now do you would like would you
like to import these conflicts by
turning away from Turkey this is not a
thing that we can trade of learning
something else
so Turkey can do whatever turkey wants
to do cause off they help Europe and the
Netherlands with a refugee crisis and
they are fighting for Europe on the
borders of Turkey this is what you want
to tell me no I what I want to tell you
I tell you myself and what I'm telling
you is that Turkey has so many of these
border conflicts and that it would be
very unwise to simply toss away the very
important alliance that we have now is
it difficult yes it is are we worried
about
Turkey's is leading us yes we are but we
also have a situation to solve in Syria
we have a situation with Iran we have a
situation in northern Iraq we have a
situation where the curse do you think
we can solve them without Turkey and you
have a problem also with Russia which
concerns you oh I want to move on this
question
in fact about Russian influence and
Western elections including the one you
to take place here next week about that
I'm not overly concerned but one should
be if one looks at the reports that came
out from the hacking of the Democratic
National Committee in the American
elections that we saw in November so
what we have done here is now we have
basically taken care that the elections
that will take place next week in our
country will be done by manual voting
which is of course yeah but that doesn't
mean that the manipulation can't happen
before informations which are not true
things were on the social media Russia
as interfere your own interior ministers
warned of interference in the vote he
said he could not rule out state actors
trying to influence political decisions
he means Moscow he means the Kremlin
curling so I can't rule it out either
because I don't have the I don't have
the possibility to see what he sees he
is in the position to also look into the
information that comes up through the
security services and the intelligence
services I simply have to rely on what
he tells me
so are we visited uhland are we on the
lookout yes we are
but um Russia as such I think also here
we still need to have a nuanced position
yes Russia is in a position and they
were actually stated so where they would
like to see to certain degree the
European Union and NATO
falling apart or that the glue between
the member states is getting less firm
at the same time I think we need to have
a almost a a trilateral approach towards
Russia we need to show that we are
serious about our values so if they do
not live up to Minsk if they keep on
annexing countries like they did with
Crimea we need to sanction them we need
to put the power in the fist of economic
sanctions in place but we also need to
flex our muscles like we do currently
with some of the military maneuvers in
Poland and in the Baltic States the
Netherlands is participating in that we
are flying over the Baltic States in
order to protect their borders and we're
doing exercises in Poland but we also
need to extend an open hand to Russia
because at the end of the day Russia is
not going to move Russia if you treat
them as an enemy then we will not get
any further let's talk about a friend
you you chair the Defense Committee and
Parliament you are also a member of the
Dutch delegation to the NATO
Parliamentary Assembly Donal Trump
raised concerns about Washington's
commitment to NATO he called the
alliance absolute is not absolute it's
it's obviously not obsolete and Donald
Trump as far as the president is capable
of staying on one position for one day
at least has a Minister of Defense
mattis who is very well known here in
Europe and who has stated and restated a
teenager is our only only security
guarantee okay if it is like that why
don't you invest well we we have to
invest more and that's thank god okay
where are we now the two percent was
promised well you know well thus and
1.2 percent what are you we are 1.1 and
we're going up to European when are you
going to the two percent which are
promised well if
I'm not going to put a date on that
because in order to get to the 2% we
need to do such a humongous that's Donna
Trump is right when he says Europe isn't
paying why he has to pay why America is
to pay John F Kennedy was already right
when he said it at those days we were
still having to pay you promised I mean
this was promised between the the
countries and according to Stockholm
International Peace Research Institute
you have that means the Netherlands
spent 2% in defense since 95 these are
two decades and still you are even not
near by to the two percent why not I
mean you said this is a crucial
institution for your defence policy no I
didn't say that 2% is a crucial incident
I say what I said
yes so well let's let's go back to what
was promised in Wales because there the
2% was was reconfirmed the 2% is an
ambition it's it is a promise to to go
in that direction turnitin I don't know
there's not too many countries that I
know of apart from those who are already
spending it that have put a date on this
now let me let me give you Greece and
the Netherlands I think Greece is
spending up way above the 2% but what
are they doing - for NATO the Dutch
however and although we're spending not
enough and as far as I'm concerned our
spending should go up tremendously have
you ever heard the expression bang for
buck now we might not be spending all
the bucks that the Americans would like
us to see and I agree with them but we
do produce the banks sir because we're
there we were the fourth country that
actually followed the United States in
the war against ISIL over Iraq in order
to free up the gcd
population on the mount of Sinjar we're
one of the first that answered the call
in Afghanistan we're still there we are
in Mali the biggest fighting operation
that the UN has ever seen and we're
doing so much more
let me try to quote another sentence of
the NATO report despite the best efforts
of the Netherlands Armed Forces the
ability to conduct full spectrum of
patience is now in doubt the arm and
force are spread so thinly I know that
we cannot continue this I mean the army
although providing in many many we have
about 15 operations around the world but
we need to do something very quickly in
order to get them up to a level where
they can sustain themselves and this
they can't today they can today but they
can't go on if we do not change
something now now and that's how didn't
work we may be here thank you very much
for being here conflicts without leisure
to talk it was thank you very much
[Music]
you